so today i'm going to talk about data
discovery and how you can get more
with metadata and query logs through
data discovery
a little bit about myself i've worked in
and with data for the last 13 years and
primarily as a software engineer data
analyst data scientist and product
manager and i started a company in 2014
called concourse systems where we built
a distributed stream processing
framework we were acquired by akamai and
now it's a product called the iot edge
connect that processes mqtt data from
sensors and also
does messaging for global consumer
electronics companies and automotive
companies
from working with a lot of enterprises
at akamai one thing that i've noticed is
that with the cloud things are getting
easier to collect and compute data
but
understanding what the data is about and
how you can use that data is still very
complex
and
i felt like
this is basically the next frontier of
challenge that everyone is going to face
so at select star which is now the
company i'm working on
our mission is to make data easy
and the first
step to that is
solving this problem of data discovery
and at selex star we define this as
how you can find and understand data
so if we were to think about how we can
understand data
the data value itself
is a point of time
but in order for you to truly understand
and utilize that data you also need to
know what the context that data is in
so
how that data was initially generated
and where it is currently being used and
how it's being used so we call this a
data context
and what we try to do is to at select
star is
to automate generating this data context
for our customers
and
this is not necessarily a
um
like a super straightforward effort
primarily because the way that the data
is currently being consumed and used in
a lot of companies are all
dissegregated and
it is it happens over multiple different
stacks and in multiple different ways
different business teams and data teams
will create their own models and
dashboards and their data pipelines and
it can get really jumbled and just
becomes a mess
so how do we really try to get meaning
out of this mess
and one i would say i'm trying to
simplify just for this talk but the main
two ingredients that we use as select
star are metadata and core logs
so as data practitioners i'm sure you
guys are all very much aware of how
database inside the logs we will track
everything
so first of all at select star we use
metadata
which is basically your information
schema systems tables which tells us
what exists inside your data warehouse
where they exist what the structure
looks like like your databases schemas
tables and columns how many there are
and where they are located
it's kind of like a map of what what the
data is let's call it our local map
and on top of that
we use query logs so raw log of the
database
to define how that data has been used
inside the system
so just like any user activity log that
you would track from the query logs you
can see who ran
what query meaning who touched this data
and how
when
and what was that result about
so combining all this together and
aggregating it you can start answering
questions like this automatically
because now you have this context like
uh
what data do we actually have today
and where did they come from
and how what because of that what does
it really represent
and
is this actually up to date when's the
last time was it's up to date and uh
are there other people that are also
using this data today and if so where is
it being used and how is it being used
and by just looking at the structure of
the data you can also find out are there
other related or similar data sets that
exist in the database
and last but not least who are the right
people to ask questions about the data
set or the report that you're looking at
so that's basically what we do in a
nutshell
and today at this talk i wanted to show
you how it actually works underneath so
if you are a data practitioner you can
also try
finding out more about your own data
warehouse yourself
so
here are five different examples that i
brought up
that you can utilize
first starting with data usage data
freshness
data
user behavior cost analysis and data
dependencies
um
i'm going to use snowflake as an example
uh
but each database is slightly different
but you can kind of see snowflake as a
kind of an example that you can also use
so first and foremost let's start with
data usage
so within the metadata of the database
and within snowflake this is primarily
under the schema of a column usage and
within account usage you can find views
that are called tables databases schemas
just to understand what actually exists
and what the status of there
so whether it has been actually deleted
created or if it's active
and from here just by simply aggregating
how many tables are there are per schema
and per database you may be able to find
out different databases that doesn't
have any tables anymore
or it was created but the data the etl
job network filled in the tables
if you were to combine this with query
logs
then you can also find out somewhat of
that usage of regardless of how many
tables the database has
how many people are actually utilizing
this database
are there actually a select query that
runs here
and what kind of select queries and is
that coming from either a bi tool or an
individual users
so by understanding data usage through a
simple
aggregation like this
you'll be able to find out which tables
schemas or
databases to deprecate
and save any storage cost
as well as reduce
any uh
any
confusion to your data team that are
accessing your database every day
so that's one way that a lot of our
customers use selectstar
to find which data sets to deprecate and
remodel based on usage
the next one that i have is data
freshness
within the systems table and when you
are looking into the actual
tables
information
there are road counts and also the size
of the table that you can get
this is interesting because now a lot of
companies run either dvt or airflow to
continuously rebuild their tables or
incrementally fill the tables with their
data
and with this you can kind of basically
see
at that point of time how big that table
is
but this is only that point of time
and if you were to start monitoring this
and track this every hour every day then
you maybe start to see some patterns
like did this table actually get uh did
did it actually get created in the right
way
do we have all the data in place
and if there is an anomaly like on
tuesday there actually isn't zero row
count something must have failed
you can basically find this pretty
quickly by just getting a stat on
from the metadata itself
by having a money rating like this
you can basically find out of any
issues that might happen
way earlier than your business
stakeholder for example
other ways to find out the data
freshness you can also look at the last
altered or last created
and also the actual ddl or dml query
types which are all the parts that we
also use as select star to make it very
very precise
the next one that i have is user
behavior
and that's primarily on the query
history side and i'll try to move this a
little bit more quickly here
so here
what we do a lot is aggregating what's
inside the query history so who ran what
queries against what
and from here
just from having a high level analysis
you can see that dvt is the top user
that is
consuming most of doing most of the
queries you can also see the user dave
is running four times more queries than
other individual users like john or
erica
and this might be because you know
dave's just a power user
and but if you were to lay this out
along with the actual computation and
the query execution time
you'll be also able to find out how much
this might be costing the company
because of their queries
and
because
including snowflake a lot of modern data
warehouses are focused on
charging you by compute
understanding these expensive queries
who runs those queries is this a regular
job or is this an ad hoc job
is something that really gives you a
clear clarifying picture if you were to
let's say remodel your data warehouse
so this is uh
this is a one part about the user
behavior and cost
the next part
is data dependencies
or what we call data lineage i think
there has been a couple other talks
about data lineage as well this is a
very simple
example of data lineage where um you're
just looking at uh m copy table that was
created from amp
a lot of data warehouses support and
give you functions that you can use to
get the ddl or how that table has been
created
and
this is just a snowflake example where a
function you can run of get ddl and you
can get the actual create statement
what we do at select star underneath is
by parsing through the sql queries here
map each column based on where it's
coming from and also define how that
column itself was degenerated
in this case each column is coming the
data is coming directly from
the um table there hasn't been any
let's say there is a somewhat filtering
but there hasn't been any aggregation or
uh transformation
this information is all very useful
especially when you are trying to do a
few things that involves data
dependencies
for example this is more of a
larger example of a screenshot that i
brought from our data lineage
here you can see that a few things you
can find out one as a impact analysis if
i were to change the column price then i
know that there will be
uh
six other look overview that's probably
gonna fail
um
if i were to
find out try to find out where this
dashboard or chart was generated from
data language is another way to really
quickly understand uh where the data is
has really come from and how it came
from two other ways that we also use
data lineage for our customers is one
propagating your classification or
column level tagging
so if you were to mark any column as a
pii you can propagate that tag to other
views dashboards or any other tables
that takes that data as is
and similarly we also
make our customers data dictionary at
the fullest by
helping them to replicate any of their
data descriptions or documentation
throughout the lineage as well
so lineage is really handy to have
because without lineage you will
basically every time you're trying to
make a change in metadata you will have
to ask someone in your team
and you might you will have to wait for
an answer and people's memory may not be
super correct and having a lineage that
can be up to date with what's happening
in your data stack that um
basically updates itself is a basically
a clear picture that you can use when
you are operating with a large data
warehouse
so
i hope you can
utilize some of the tips i shared here
some of the friendly reminder every
database is different i gave an example
of a snowflake so it was pretty
straightforward by using just the
account usage if you were to try to do
this on
redshift then there will be different
settings that you have to put on uh
because the audit log or the activity
log is not enabled by default and you
will also have to define which s3 bucket
you want to output the queries to
but
nonetheless this is really fun because
for us because we get to find out and
tell our customers all the insights and
things that's happening within their
data warehouse and bi tools and further
other applications about their data that
they didn't know about
and this is really just
i would say still we're just scratching
the surface here and there's a lot more
interesting insights and
action items that you can actually get
out of from analyzing your metadata and
query logs
so
you can also you can definitely try it
out or you can also try out select star
if you want to just get it
get your insights in one click
thank you
you